bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
fine io sono quello che leggete con
questo incredibile effetto quello lì è
oggi sono col signor salvo cio san salvo
power salvo power sia un suo modern
quello che ha detto salvo che a new art
light sensor dobbiamo morire tante volte
una mappa dove moriamo ok vogliamo ai
ragazzi nati tra tutti quello che dice
salvo ok perché lui parla inglese allora
andiamo subito andiamo a dire in
italiano adesso il poeta è uscito o mio
dio ma che è successo è successo specie
l'ho fatta ho vinto ma perche egli e di
continuo
eh sì ma che stai dicendo tebow ma c'è
anche un piccolo bug che mi ha fatto
sposare allo sponda e thereau ma è
impossibile usare ancora che non knock
on line mezzo è impossibile perché mi sa
di vetro e invece ce l'ho fatta le
schede sono dentro con vietti o trophy
aspetta tutto non va dai tubi trophy e
non mi ha dato nulla ti da le trofie no
non mi ha dato trophy
ecco l'ho fatta salvo e ma non funziona
altro filo salvo nel senso di salvo sono
stato e non lo fa e lo prendi niente poi
ok abbiamo elettorali ecc abbiamo il
trophy che sarebbe dove non lo vedete ma
è nostro non è evidente ma l'abbiamo
fatto dove che noi che si è partiti
questo quale secondo ice ice spikes o
che non ci vuole bagarre tra dolci wired
dolci mori spikes
ma già stato io non sono stato io te lo
giochi è stato sta vincendo e anche così
via
allora l'acqua a sinistra budan colata
ecco subito tentativo perché sei
incredibile il milan non sono un fatto
avete fatto moltissimo è stato forte
scegli il tuo buco scegliamo il mikasa
luogo il nuova croma collegato scegliamo
il nostro amico preferito salvo borja
valero è anno abbiamo ascoltato dello
sport anche cassone nou dove di buttarti
giochiamo sanità
no no no di vedere la mia che fa
trattano quasi solo
eccolo e lo fa proprio lui a me ce ne
sono ci sono
porca vacca la benetton dall'alba allora
torni a lab
ma attorno tantissimo e io non so dove
il becco un hub e quindi abbiamo scelto
un nostro buco ai balconi chiusi qua qua
che questo bianco arcavacata bianco
libero
ok aspetta visto che la fede calcistica
che imbianca ce la fa ce la fa ce la
faccio fatta davvero fortissimo vento di
abb lo fa beaten black and white
tensione post proprio lui le schiave fra
questo sembra davvero semplice in realtà
c'è un botto d'acqua e se infatti l'ho
fatto subito e io sommato se che altro
su radio in perso troppo forte questo
c'è poi sono morto miliardo di volte in
più di te però hai ragione né ragione
allora devi vedere quelli che abbiamo
fatta spetta a caldo e freddo
ok volte ma 8 influenze allora quale
acqua tetti los punitiva
stiamo best to start perché non
funzionano stickman bloc
vai vai vai bene cosa ce l'ho fatta ma
dove ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta allora
aspetta guarda se vi guarda guarda qua
c'è solo un piccolo piccolo spiraglietto
diagonali esatto esatto l'altra lava
acqua e ma è complicatissimo qua poi
alla fine tutta la va alla fine come fai
del beccare uno spot
io l'ho fatto è relativa cioè che la
società era acqua questa con l'angolo
provarlo alla fiat sul lo trovate c'è un
blocco d'accio marocco da qualsiasi e lo
centra proprio lui ma davvero è la
finisce così la 400 a chi fa qui allora
e niente betpro giorni non presidi
sbatto non c'era
sto facendo schifo io questa questi sia
così ma a giudicare la tipo morto dentro
non era così rock mi7 allo sposo ha
donato andiamo amici bureau capoferro
buonanotte è difficilissimo c'è bella la
seconda quel mondo degli shinobi osta
dei che eccolo ce la fa ce la fa proprio
lui uno schifo ma livelli indicibile
allora valore trovi l'ho fatto l'ho
fatto con l'ho fatto
back to the hub poi ci siamo pro gamer
abbiamo fatto tutta la trafila di destra
quasi no no no mancava questo gesù
cripta cielo quasi ha comunque no a jesi
tu devi solo becca il timing della
pressione dei tasti già fatta ragazzi
sono stati veramente entra il 34 più 8 a
questa quindi esatto cairo secrets e
scaler pescara che con secret ma calda
palais design droga l'altro sfregio
uguale da lo metti lo spawn questo andrò
avanti non mi ispira molto perché vedo
tanti buchini piccolini ok c'è
nell'acqua e ce l'ho fatta subito ma
volete se non sono tipo non è diventato
minecraft non è vero lì bisogna saperlo
salto solo a posto back to the a bada la
paura insomma fortissimo sono faccia
massimo
non so come mai queste matrix si chiama
matrix
rimane poi ci siamo mai la prima tassa
del primo tentativo più o tentativo
proprio lui non ci credo è vero non ho
fatto subito ho fatto sul ritorno ci
sono delle liane che ti fermano ma non è
vero che lo giuro studiando solo
fortissimo lo stato è successo sono
troppo forte
cavolo ma non solo faccio te lo giuro mi
butto caso serve step by step by step by
step
e allora è molto semplice sono due salti
in totale è un salto lunghissimo fino al
primo stop è già quello sano e l'indice
tra l'altro stop
l'ho fatto e da sotto qua ok ci prova
cipolla che cosi bene bene bene
jump on the fans che face a quella jump
giampà e difenditi io smetterò di fare
video con famigerata arrivo ce l'ho
fatta ce l'hai fatta
come fa saltare point studios check
point con chrome è ancora lungo ma basta
cielo sarà il mio diventato un parco no
che schifo da riproviamoci paesi 11 le
proposte di vigilare e di cento direi
porco demonio 6 difficile questo è
veramente difficile ragazzi ma ora io
andrei uno alla volta così evitiamo di
ok
vado a morire tipo che imbalzano porto
salvo ottimo ottimo tranquillo non devi
fare così
eccomi e rimbalza tirato la testata tra
e lo stato ci siamo calati un check
point ragazzine sicuramente difficile
vari facciamo più usate cima era
veramente impossibile questa volta si
può fare solo per questa volta di pelo
prima di saltare allora ce l'ho fatta
esatto
speriamo di vederti partire eccomi qua
magenta lucani sono devi farlo
guarda non lo sapevo ma dei suoi ma
l'hai detto mi sto cagando sotto ok
parlare tutto giusto
ok amico mio stiamo forzare botti molto
basta non finisce ecco indetti lo trova
mancio d'altro fillmore chissenefrega
torniamo alla brano voglio più vederlo
suo livello che basta oggi vediamo
perché non funzionano come un blog ma
questo l'ho sbagliato la versione sa
cos'è sta roba di beccare
certo va beh dopo ti sia un fregio nel
mondo
ragazzi siamo agli ultimi due la
pazienza ci sta divorando l'intestino
non riesco a prendere questo buco
ecco questa è la frase che non vorrei
mai sentirti dire però non viene ce lo
faccia ha già fatto ci ha fatto
giampiero si aspetta ma io voglio castro
fateci ho fatto ciò ha fatto ciò fatto
ciò fa mai vinto
ho vinto l'ultimo livello molti signori
library very very easy ultime verifiche
periferici anche perché era dal fango
andiamo ok questo in una botta sola
salgono al cielo si può notare un primo
hai subito o il cattivo vai e supporto o
sei di uno sopra no
bene sono rivolto sono molto rimbalzando
però quindi perché c'è da rimbalzare sì
che era e non lo slime pro bus tram easy
green is if this is out e google ecco
ecco ecco ecco ecco fatto è che ci sono
per contro cuore siamo morti però che
l'evento ruote maialino morti
no per due morti è battuto
mai battuto la libreria e non solo amico
io abbiamo battuto tutti i livelli tutti
sentito io la concludere qua ragazze
siete d'accordo anche se comunque stato
continua a picchiarmi basta perché deve
vivere 130 mattina di 130 ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto ringrazio salvo però
verso artecipato come sempre
iscrivetevi al canale e noi ci vediamo
ora possiamo vita gang belle ragazze
[Musica]